الى تونس حيث تتواصل عمليات التصويت في
اول انتخابات تشريعيه منذ اعلان الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد عن اجراءات استثنائيه في
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو 2021
ووسط مقاطعه طيف واسع من الاحزاب والهيئه
المعارضه
بينهم 120 امراه فقط على 161 مقعدا منها
10 مخصصه للتونسيين بالخارج ويعتبر اغلب
المترشحين من المستقلين غير المعروفين
بنشاط سياسي سابق بينما ينتمي اخرون الى
احزاب داعمه للرئيس فتجر هذه الانتخابات
في ظل دستور جديد منح الرئيس صلاحيات
واسعه بينما قلص صلاحيات البرلمان وتدخل
عمليات الاقتراع بالخارج يومها الاخير في
ثلاث دوائر فقط من بين 10 بعد ان علق
المسار الانتخابي في سبع منها بسبب عدم
وجود مترشحين
اعتبر الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد الانتخابات
التشريعيه فرصه تاريخيه لتغيير ولقطع
الطريق على من نصب انفسهم اوصياء على تونس
وفقه تعبيره
في الانتخابات واضاف ان على مجلس النواب
القادم العمل على تلبيه المطالب
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه لتونسي
لا تحتجه الا الى ضمائركم
ولا يغرنكم ابدا
خطاب هؤلاء
المسكين
وخطاب هؤلاء الذين وضعوا اقنعه على وجوههم
والدسوا بين صفوفكم
انتبهوا اليهم
وانتبه خاصه لمن يدفع الاموال لشراء الذمم
لانهم لا يعتبرون المواطن مواطنا بل
يعتبرونه ورقه اقتراع توضع في صندوق
الاضرار
ان شاء الله